fan de science les chercheurs de l'IRSN
du Vésinet ouvrent les portes de leur
laboratoire tout le week-end pour la
deuxième année consécutive au programme
découverte du site visite et ateliers
autour du thème de la radioactivité
dans le cadre des fêtes de la science à
l'irassan ont souhaite expliquer notre
activité pour la population du Vésinet
pour nos nouveaux voisins les
coquartiers de la princesse ce que nous
avons préparé est adapté pour un public
de 7 à 77 ans il y aura des conférences
thématiques il y aura des ateliers
pédagogiques vous pourrez visiter nos
laboratoires notamment ce nouveau
bâtiment chaque année les scientifiques
prélèvent plus de 6000 échantillons pour
mesurer leur radioactivité
eau végétaux sédiments ou encore
aliments grâce à cette nouvelle
plateforme de haute technologie
d'analyse les scientifiques peuvent
analyser plus de 150 échantillons par
jour une faculté unique c'est l'expert
public qui est en charge de la recherche
et de l'expertise dans le domaine de la
matière radiologique
et de tout ce qui est risque nucléaire
ça veut dire que l'IRSN fait notamment
l'analyse des dossiers que peuvent
déposer des exploitants pour démarrer
une installation nucléaire pour faire
une extension ou pour tout ce qui
concerne la vie des installations
nucléaires mais l'Institut a également
pour mission de surveiller
l'environnement et ce depuis que
l'industrie du nucléaire existe ça veut
dire deux choses ça veut dire étudier et
voir l'influence des installations
nucléaires sur l'environnement dans leur
dans le cadre de leur fonctionnement
normal comme tout industrie une
installation nucléaire conduit à des
rejets dans l'environnement qui est
réglementé qui sont autorisés mais on a
aussi une mission de surveillance de
l'ensemble du territoire et on vérifie
que les niveaux sont finalement aux
quantités attendues gratuit et ouvert à
tous sans inscription c'est l'occasion
unique de découvrir ce site historique